[Musique]
c'est l'initiative en fait de deux
passionnés de jazz
qui au gré de leurs déplacements un peu
dans le monde ont découvert le le fait
de se retrouver après le travail d'où
les afterworks
un jeudi par mois dans le foyer du
théâtre du vésinet on accueille les gens
à partir de 19h quand on fait venir des
clubs dans ce club des groupes de
renommée mondiale
vous y rencontrer beaucoup de gens des
gens sympathiques des gens amoureux des
gens qui ont envie de faire partager un
sortant de choses d'échangés permettra
lieu d'échangé un lieu de découverte un
lieu agréable et un lieu un petit peu
d'évasion par les temps qui courent on a
pas mal besoin
la prochaine date c'est tricia evy qui
vient avec un kart est donc piano
contrebasse batterie et chant bien
évidemment elle va reprendre des
standards du jazz du zouk de la pop
aussi un petit peu la chanson française
jazzifier
[Musique]
un pierrick pédron le 10 mars pierrick
pédron c'est un très grand saxophoniste
puisqu'il a été
il a eut reçu une victoire
aux awards du jazz il ya quelques années
il viendra lui en carte est également et
puis ensuite on aura le 7 avril emmanuel
bex qui vient là en trio avec son fils à
la batterie et un contrebassiste
[Musique]